Now we're going to turn our attention to a different type of puzzle.
This is called a cryptarithmetic problem.
"Crypt-" for cryptography--secret writing---and arithmetic for arithmetic--
doing addition and other types of problems,
and the idea here is that each of these letters of the alphabet stands for
some digit from 0 to 9.
The problem is to figure out which digit stands for which
such that the equation will be correct.
Some people call these alphametics--is another name for them.
They're a puzzle for humans to work out because there are so many possibilities,
and humans are limited in the speed in which they can mark them out.
But there are some types of inferences that they can make.
For example, in this addition problem here we have an addition problem of
of two 3-digit numbers, and the result is a 4-digit number.
E is that fourth digit, so what does that tell us about what the letter E must stand for?
What digit it must stand for?
Do you think E should be 1 or 2 or 3 or 4 or 9?